hiren a bit of news in the Doctor Who
verse is that we're getting a female
doctor what was your reaction when you
heard that role and I'm like your own
Sade and of course you can and then and
now we have one it's just and I'm
delighted I'm completely delighted what
do you say it's not always the case what
do you say to the haters the internet
haters I'd like to say two things first
of all if you ever watch Star Trek
Voyager
Captain Janeway came in the only female
captain and absolutely nailed it so we
know that that can work and second of
all just relax well now we're in home
release territory for guardians of the
galaxy to talk a little bit about what
happens we learned yondu's to journey
comes to an end did you always know he
wasn't gonna make it - sure it does not
come to an end what does that mean death
is not the end you know you're gonna
really you just exploded the internet I
know don't do that no but I mean my in
my own belief
when of being gases from this this stage
we move on to something else are we
gonna see you on do again oh yeah how do
you think mantis and nebula are gonna
hand especially nebula handle angsty
teenage group I think that she's very
unimpressed by group in general and
everybody thinks that he's cute a nebula
doesn't see that so I think that you
know what I actually think she's gonna
connect with the angsty teenage version
that's actually a good point yeah II
know herself haha
how do you think a mantis was gonna
handle angsty Gert you know she's gonna
do it what she does when she doesn't
really know what she do she's just gonna
tilt her head like a dog that is a you
know I think question
at d23 we saw the Avengers infinity war
trailer and how you guys come in contact
with the Avengers first of all are you a
little are you a little bitter that
you're not mixing it up with the
Avengers no not bitter at all I mean ya
know that that's gonna be a brutal piece
III have a feeling it's gonna be very
exciting and just very tough it's gonna
be a lot of discipline I don't know how
physical you guys got you know in the
comments it's very physical and very
deadly and yeah this is scary one to be
involved